hola espero que no te importe que esté
comiendo de hecho este es mi primer
plato para mi cumpleaños los escritores
hicieron un guión en donde podía comer
todo el tiempo y no puedo pensar en una
mejor manera de demostrar el
funcionamiento del sistema digestivo la
serie de órganos huecos que utilizamos
para descomponer y procesar los
nutrientes y la energía que necesitamos
para funcionar
oh espera un segundo sí recuerdo
correctamente la digestión es realmente
bastante asquerosa así que tal vez no
debería estar comiendo ahora o no
importa camarero
el sistema digestivo es tan fundamental
que básicamente es el paso número 1 en
la guía de cómo hacer un animal
probablemente recuerdes que durante el
desarrollo embrionario de la mayoría de
los animales el tracto digestivo es lo
primero que se forma cuando hablas
tulane ese pequeño montón de células que
todos solíamos ser se convierte en un
pequeño montón de células con un tubo
que lo atraviesa ese tubo es su sistema
digestivo y casi todos los animales
tienen un sistema digestivo de algún
tipo pero no todos son iguales para nada
de hecho los aspectos digestivos están
especialmente adaptados al
comportamiento alimentario y a la dieta
de los animales por ejemplo una mosca
doméstica comer principalmente alimentos
líquidos o finamente granulados pero
antes de hacerlo tiene que vomitar sus
jugos digestivos sobre su almuerzo y
luego dejar que lo dijeran por un tiempo
antes de meterlos a su boca si lo
hiciéramos así las primeras citas serían
menos comunes
la mayoría de los vertebrados ponen
comida en un extremo del tubo y el
sistema digestivo la procesa y luego
elimina los desechos del otro extremo
del tubo sin complicaciones ni problemas
lo bueno de esto es que todo este
proceso está a cargo de nuestro sistema
nervioso autónomo por lo que no tenemos
que pensar en él hasta quizá el último
paso cuando estamos en el tráfico y
tomamos dos tazas de café y un muffin de
salvado entonces tenemos que pensar un
poco en ello entre los vertebrados el
tracto digestivo puede ser corto o largo
o tener órganos que hacen cosas
diferentes dependiendo de cuáles sean
sus hábitos alimenticios por ejemplo los
perros son en su mayoría carnívoros y
carroñeros comen carne principalmente a
veces esa carne ha estado muerta por un
tiempo así que el sistema digestivo del
perro se ha desarrollado para absorber
tantos nutrientes como sea posible de
los alimentos y luego depositarlos en el
césped de alguien en un periodo de
alrededor de seis horas los perros
tienen un tracto digestivo
extremadamente corto porque si tienes la
costumbre de comer carne podrida es
mejor digerirla rápidamente si no lo
haces las malas bacterias que vivían en
la carcasa de ese armadillo se
instalarán en tu intestino y te causarán
mucho dolor por otro
las vacas tardan mucho mucho mucho
tiempo en digerir sus alimentos
alrededor de 80 horas porque tienen que
procesar plantas principalmente pastos
el pasto tiene muchísima celulosa y la
evolución aún no ha producido un animal
que pueda fabricar un ácido estomacal o
una enzima lo suficientemente resistente
como para descomponer la celulosa así
que las vacas tienen microorganismos en
sus intestinos que descomponen la
celulosa este proceso requiere un
estómago de cuatro cámaras cada una con
una micro ecología ligeramente diferente
y mucha masticación o regurgitación y re
masticación del pasto antes de que pase
por completo la naturaleza está llena de
locas historias de digestión y
sinceramente desearía tener tiempo para
contarlas todas pero centrémonos en la
digestión humana de ahora en adelante
principalmente porque probablemente eres
humano no suponemos nada aquí y quería
saber cómo tu cuerpo hace todo esto y
segundo los humanos en realidad tienen
un sistema digestivo todo propósito
bastante bueno somos omnívoros después
de todo comemos plantas y carne por lo
que nuestros sistemas están
generalizados para manejar todo tipo de
cosas como la mayoría de los animales
los humanos tienen un montón de
diferentes ácidos
extractos digestivos que descomponen los
alimentos para que sus cuerpos los
puedan absorber y usar pero el secreto
para una digestión exitosa es maximizar
el área superficial en más de una forma
la primera forma de maximizar el área
superficial es en la comida misma
digamos que le doy un mordisco a esta
manzana ahora tengo un pedazo de manzana
en la boca y tengo enzimas en saliva que
comienzan a descomponer la
inmediatamente la parte exterior del
gran pedazo si me traigo este trozo
entero no solo me dolería un montón sino
que el resto de mi sistema digestivo
tendría dificultades para lidiar con él
porque la mayoría de las enzimas y los
ácidos tendrían la misma dificultad para
descomponer este gran trozo sólido pero
cuando uso más increíbles dientes para
masticar este trozo de manzana de
repente hay el doble el triple el
cuádruple de la superficie de la comida
estoy haciendo pedacitos del gran trozo
de manzana para los humanos la
masticación es clave porque descomponer
los alimentos en trozos cada vez más
pequeños permite que las enzimas y los
ácidos lleguen a ellos y después de que
nuestros dientes hayan hecho las piezas
lo suficientemente pequeñas los químicos
las descomponen aún más hasta que están
lo suficientemente
para que nuestros cuerpos absorban
nutrientes de ellas pero lo importante
no es sólo la superficie de los
alimentos el área superficial del tracto
digestivo también es clave para todo el
proceso la última vez hablé sobre cómo
tenemos un montón de superficie en
nuestros pulmones para absorber
toneladas de oxígeno de una vez bueno
nuestro sistema digestivo funciona de la
misma manera la mayor parte de la
absorción de nutrientes ocurre en
nuestro intestino delgado y la longitud
del intestino delgado del adulto humano
promedio es de aproximadamente 7 metros
además dentro de nuestro intestino
delgado hay un montón de pequeños
pliegues y pequeñas fibras absorbentes
que a su vez tienen fibras absorbentes y
no no he dicho mal las fibras tienen
fibras así es como trabaja nuestros
intestinos para aumentar su área
superficial en el episodio anterior me
impresionó que los pulmones tengan una
superficie total de 75 metros cuadrados
bueno el intestino delgado tiene una
superficie de 250 metros cuadrados
es un poco asqueroso no quisiera haberlo
extendido sobre una cancha de tenis ni
nada pero me estoy adelantando aquí la
digestión no comienza en el intestino
delgado agente comienza en la boca
ahora como pueden ver este pan éxito
caliente está roto
de algún tipo de masa si podemos
llamarlo así el pan es un almidón que se
descompone en cosas y cuando empiezo a
roer un pedazo de pan
podríamos morder el exterior aquí es
principalmente para las glándulas en mi
boca comienzan a crear saliva que
contiene amilasa salival una enzima
diseñada para descomponer el almidón en
glucosa cuanto más mastico más amilasa
llegará a todos los lados del pan y es
por eso que cuanto más masticamos el pan
más dulce sabe la amilasa realmente no
le hace mucho al relleno de queso de
esta cosa pero tengo otras enzimas y
ácidos en el sistema que trabajarán en
él más adelante pero voy a masticar
todas esas cosas realmente bien para que
esas otras enzimas puedan hacer su
trabajo más tarde me voy a tragar todo
esto entonces el panecillo masticado
pasa por mi faringe o garganta hasta el
esófago que lo lleva a mi estómago de
hecho hay un pequeño colgajo de tejido
llamado epiglotis que bloquea la tráquea
cuando trago para que la comida no
termine en mi sistema respiratorio esta
bola de comida que acabo de tragar tiene
un nombre científico se llama bolo me
conduce una especie de ola de acción
muscular por el esófago hasta el
estómago esta contracción en forma de
onda en los músculos lisos alrededor del
tubo de
se llama peristaltismo y es básicamente
cómo se logra la mayor parte del
movimiento en el sistema digestivo el
panecillo está en mi estómago ahora que
es donde la comida realmente comienza a
ser maltratada el estómago básicamente
adopta un enfoque rudo para la digestión
no pierde el tiempo es como un mezclador
de cemento agitado que puede contraerse
y expandirse con estos grandes pliegues
musculares en forma de acordeón llamados
arrugas gástricas el trabajo del
estómago es girar todo una y otra vez
alisar y mezclar todas las piezas con su
cóctel de ácidos y enzimas llamados jugo
gástrico el jugo gástrico está compuesto
principalmente de ácido clorhídrico una
enzima llamada piscina y algo de mucosa
y agua el ácido clorhídrico tiene un ph
de aproximadamente 1 que es lo
suficientemente fuerte como para que si
lo tienes en tu mano te produzca una
quemadura química entonces el ácido
descompone las cosas y con suerte mata
la mayoría de las bacterias que podrías
encontrar en tu comida y la persona
comienza a descomponer las proteínas en
aminoácidos ahora esa cosa es importante
está allí para proteger tu estómago para
que no se digiera a sí mismo cuando no
tiene suficiente mucosidad tienes
úlceras pépticas
cuando el revestimiento del estómago
entra en contacto directo con el ácido
del estómago y esa agua está ahí para
hacer que todo esté aguado porque lo que
quieres para cuando la comida sale del
estómago es como que es una cosa líquida
que seguro recuerdas de la última vez
que tuviste un virus estomacal sabía que
esta conversación se iba a poner un poco
asquerosa y no quería meterle también
diarrea porque ya sabes he estado
comiendo pero cuando algo malo está
sucediendo en tu tracto digestivo en tu
cuerpo no se preocupa demasiado por la
absorción de nutrientes solo quieres
sacar el quimo de allí el timo es lo que
ves cuando ya te imaginás hay una
pequeña válvula o esfínter entre el
estómago y el intestino delgado que
regula la cantidad de quimo que ingresa
al intestino delgado y cuando ingresa
allí el intestino delgado comienza en el
duodeno aquí es donde ocurre gran parte
de la acción del intestino delgado me
refiero a que muchas cosas se absorben y
también se secretan como el bicarbonato
que neutraliza el ácido gástrico antes
de que continúe ahora lo genial del
intestino delgado no puede ser exagerado
es la 'zona cero' para el intercambio
celular de nutrientes en la
descomposición de las grasas y de nuevo
la razón por la que es tan bueno
absorber es porque tiene mucha área
superficial para hacerlo gran parte de
esa área superficial viene del hecho de
que el intestino delgado es
tremendamente largo en un ser humano
puede oscilar entre 4.5 y 10.5 metros
pero eso no es todo el interior está
forrado con tejido epitelial que tiene
toneladas de crestas y pliegues área
superficial al máximo y en esas crestas
y pliegues se encuentran estas pequeñas
fibras de carne parecidas a p los
llamadas vellosidades cada velocidad
tiene capilares para que pueda absorber
nutrientes y checa esto cada velocidad
que mide sólo medio milímetro de largo
está cubierta de pequeñas micro
vellosidades diminutas que proporcionan
aún más superficie de hecho
aparentemente el intestino delgado tiene
una textura similar al terciopelo lo que
es genial wii y ahora tengo que tomar
una malteada fantástico otra cosa que
hace el intestino delgado con la ayuda
de su amiga la vesícula biliar es
descomponer las grasas como esta
malteada cerca de la parte superior de
tu intestino delgado hay una pequeña
tubería donde la sal biliar fabricada
por el hígado y almacenada en la
vesícula biliar se expulsa hacia el
intestino delgado
funciona como detergente para platos en
una sartén en la que acabas desde
hidalgo es una emocionante toma
moléculas de grasa hidrofóbicas y las
descompone en ácidos grasos y mono
crecer y dos que pueden ser absorbidos
por todo este tejido epitelial nunca
había probado la malteada de cacahuate
un rico después de que tu comida pasa
por esos metros y metros de intestino
delgado el timo pasa por tu esfínter y
entra al ciego si el comienzo del
intestino grueso el trabajo del
intestino grueso es eliminar la mayor
parte del agua y las sales biliares del
quimo para que no tengas diarrea
constante puedes agradecerle por eso se
llama grueso porque es más ancho que el
intestino delgado pero no es tan largo
básicamente sólo una vuelta de honor de
metro y medio alrededor del intestino
delgado y eso es todo también debería
mencionar que al final del ciego hay un
pequeño tubo donde está el apéndice
durante mucho tiempo pensamos que el
apéndice era una estructura vestigio
inútil que solíamos necesitar en algún
momento de nuestra evolución pero que ya
no necesitábamos sin embargo estudios
recientes están descubriendo que el
propósito del apéndice en los humanos
modernos es actuar
un refugio para todas las bacterias
buenas que necesitas para ayudarte a
digerir los alimentos si tienes un virus
o una intoxicación alimentaria o algo
así y todos los sistemas digestivos
vicente en menos de encima del apéndice
tiene una pequeña muestra de tus
bacterias intestinales que escupe para
ayudarte a recolonizar después de tu
enfermedad y creo que probablemente
estás familiarizado con el paso final en
el sistema digestivo y eso es defecar la
comida puede pasar hasta tres días en el
tracto digestivo y gran parte de ese
tiempo está en el intestino grueso en su
mayoría reabsorbe el exceso de agua del
ki-moon y prepara tu materia fecal para
su gran entrada al mundo y cuando está
hecho pasa a través de los esfínteres
favoritos de todos los esfínteres anales
hay dos de ellos y ya sabes salen al
mundo a buscar aventuras y ese es el
final de nuestra pequeña historia que
comenzó con el panecillo espero que te
unas a nosotros la próxima vez para más
cosas asquerosas mientras discutimos los
detalles del sistema excretor yo hasta
entonces buen provecho